good morning so thank you for attending
and like to thank the organizers for the
opportunity opportunity to speak I've
really enjoyed the conference so far
there's been a very nice a variety of
talks and I hope to make a modest
contribution to that so the goal of this
talk is to explain some general methods
in supervised machine learning from
various viewpoints from statistics and
and game theory and geometry with the
goal of providing a new way of thinking
about in approaching hopefully some
problems in general so before I get into
like to briefly introduce myself so my
background is in pure mathematics so
until about five or six years ago I was
doing research in algebraic geometry I
decided to join the tech industry at
some point for the last three and a half
years or so I've been at signal effects
so we're a metrics monitoring and
distributed tracing platform for
monitoring cloud infrastructure and and
producing alerts but the talk will have
not so much to do with work related to
that ok it is the sound all right
ok I'm hearing something whisper maybe
that's me
ok so the overall goal is to describe
some general concepts from supervised
machine learning with an eye towards
decision trees and ensembles of such and
then I'll try to view these particular
methods from the viewpoints of
statistics game theory and then
dynamical systems and geometry so there
are some parts of this that may be a bit
dry but I promise that there are
pictures at the end unless you ask
unless you has too many questions and we
don't get to those slides but there will
be some pictures ok so just as a as a as
a brief reminder or contexts that are
the the overall idea of supervised
machine learning is to use data to fit a
function that describes some outputs of
interest as as a function of the inputs
which can be observed so for example
fraud detection can be modeled as such a
problem given an incoming transaction on
a credit card say you would like to
infer or guess
from various attributes of that
transaction like what is the history of
this card was the history of this
merchant how likely is this transaction
to be fraudulent and you know very
quickly you have to make a decision
about whether or not to let it go
through or maybe you're giving loans to
people and you need to decide based on
their credit history and other
attributes which you are legally allowed
to consider the likelihood of default
whether or not they're they're likely to
pay you back so there many problems
which can be modeled in this way but the
the general mathematical framework is
that we're trying to learn a function
from some inputs that can be observed to
some outputs that we care about and so
for simplicity I'll focus on the two
class classification problem which is to
say that the output is discrete or
categorical rather than continuous and
we'll assume the input space is a
d-dimensional euclidean space so
hopefully you can model your way into
this situation and use this to handle
multi class problems if that's what
you're facing and I will then further
focus on algorithms that use as a base
decision tree so so the basic idea of a
decision tree is that you cut your
Euclidean space into regions using a
binary tree of coordinate inequalities
so the root node will say something like
the first coordinate is less than three
and if that's true you go to the to the
left child and now we'll give you some
other coordinate and some other
threshold and if not you will go to the
right subtree and you'll keep traveling
along this tree and then eventually
we'll get to a terminal region and that
will tell you something to do like vote
class one or vote class minus one that's
kind of the abstract the abstract
definition and then of course are all
these problems about given the data set
how do you produce one of these trees
and then given an incoming incoming
example how do you use this to make a
decision but sort of the the abstract
framework is a binary tree of coordinate
inequalities on euclidean space to
detect to to distinguish two classes
okay are there any any general this is
kind of the background I don't expect
you to have learned all this in the last
minute but there any questions at this
moment
it's the set of D topples of real
numbers I'm not sure what else to say
about it
so you just you're the point is that
you're allowed to have lots and lots of
features that describe your inputs like
velocity different types of velocity
measurements and different attributes of
the of the merchants so it's the usually
the job of the data scientist to produce
some gigantic feature space and then the
machine learning algorithm is supposed
to say these are the ones we care about
and this is this is the decision rule
that describes the output as a function
of these possibly very many inputs okay
okay so generally a single decision tree
is sort of terrible at making decisions
for a lot of reasons and so there's a
there's an interest in using them as a
basis for performing better classifiers
or better regressors and so as a general
motivation for ensemble methods I'd like
to explain to you how to so I used to I
used to teach if you have a class of C
students I probably shouldn't say
anything else about my teaching history
how you can make a make an a-plus out of
this okay so let's say you have a class
of 50 students and they all score about
70% on your true/false exam and somehow
they're allowed to vote on each question
definitely not allowed but if you allow
them to vote and just take the majority
vote as the as the guest for that
question what will they score okay will
it be about 70% will it be much better
hopefully shouldn't be worse so what is
the probability that the majority of
students is correct in this situation
okay well assuming that errors they make
are independent which is a huge
assumption we can use the fact that the
sum of a bunch of independent random
variables should be pretty close to its
expected value so in particular if we
have n independent Bernoulli random
variables so Bernoulli just is taking
take value 0 or 1
it takes value 1 with probability P and
value 0 with probability of 1 minus P
then if you take any of these and add
them up you should get P times n that's
about you should get and of course
there's
if you do a little bit of extra work you
can you can study how likely this this
sum is to be far from P times n and one
way to do to do this is to apply Hough
things in equality and so what this says
is that the the probability that the sum
of these n independent random variables
differs from the expected value P times
n by more than some epsilon times n
where epsilon is is quantifying the
error is less than or equal to something
which is exponential in n which is the
the sample size okay times this minus 2
and the square of the epsilon okay so
it's describing for you so of course we
expect P times N and this is saying well
what is the probability of having a
certain deviation from that well it's
this it's this exponential term okay so
this is something that we can we can
just evaluate then so our for our
particular numbers we can say well we
have 50 students that's N and the
probability of being correct is 70% so
so P is 0.7 so I I put these numbers in
for you hopefully you believe me but
anyway you get that the probability is
less than or equal to the exponential of
minus 100 times the square of the error
now since we are since I said we're 70%
correct on average we can afford four we
can afford to miss to be off by about a
fifth that that's what we would in order
to in order to still have a majority be
correct because there's a fifth between
70% and 50% so the the probability that
the majority is wrong on a given
question can be obtained by setting
epsilon equal to 1/5 in the in the
preceding inequality and then you get
the exponential of minus 4 which is a
little under 2% so you expect the grade
of over 98 that's pretty good at least
in all the classes I ever taught or or
or attended that was probably an a so
all you have to do is get these 50
students to make independent errors so
maybe you assign them different sections
of the of the book or or somehow you get
them to to produce errors which are
independent
and then as long as you can get them to
vote you can produce a better result
okay so so this motivates a various ways
of combining machine learning
classifiers which may not may not be so
so great on their own but which are a
little bit better than random maybe not
70% and whose errors can be made
independent okay and there are there are
two general frameworks for making for
forcing classifiers are encouraging
classifiers to make independent errors
and so they're generally called boosting
and and random forests so I'll I'll
first mention the the framework of the
adaboost algorithm so the idea here is
to to reweighed the training set based
on the errors that you've that you've
accumulated so far so you first weight
your training set with with every point
receiving an equal weight an equal
fraction of one and then for some number
of iterations you fit a classifier to
that training set for example you fit a
decision tree to that training set from
that you compute its weighted error rate
so how bad is it taking into account the
weights and from this you extracted
coefficient and then use this to
reweighed the training set so that you
encourage the next classifier to focus
more on the examples that you've gotten
wrong so far okay and you keep you keep
going for some amount of time say
Capital m and then at the end you output
something which is just the sign of the
weighted sum of the individual
classifiers that you obtained and so
generally at least if you if you read
this in the standard textbooks you'll
see this presented with the particular
case of the GM's being decision stumps
which is a decision tree with a single
node so it's a single feature and a
threshold on that you say if X 5 is
bigger than 3 vote yes if otherwise vote
no ok but so you can't make very good
decisions just using those but if you
form linear combinations of them using
this procedure it turns out you can make
much better decisions ok so the idea is
to deliberately force the next
classifier to focus on the
that you have so far so that's boosting
or adaptive boosting at a boost so short
and then the idea of the random forest
is somewhat different so here we
encourage randomness we encourage
independence rather just by using
randomness so in this situation we are
again producing a collection of trees
and each one is trained on a different
sample from our training set and
bootstrap just means that we sample with
with replacement and then we don't
consider all of the features all the
time at each node we consider only a
random subset of the available features
so may be the case that x10 is really
powerful at distinguishing the two
classes but we only consider 5% of the
available features and we're not going
to get that all the time and then the
the number of features that you consider
at each split is then the main thing
that controls how this how this ensemble
behaves but in general you just take a
bunch of bootstrap samples and random
subsets of the features train the trees
on those and then use a and then use an
unwitting voting to produce to produce a
prediction rule from the collection of
decision trees okay and so the hope is
that they'll be independent because
they're trained on different random
subsets and because they consider at
each node a different subset of the
available features so if something if a
phenomenon survives this process then
surely it's real okay any any questions
about these two general approaches so
one's very deliberate and focused and
ones like I don't know let's just let's
just take a bunch of random stuff and
average it out which which actually
works so so we can think about why these
work or how they work using a more
general idea of the the bias-variance
decomposition and this basically
describes the two principal sources of
error when you're when you have a
classifier so basically classifier is
unbiased if you expect the correct
answer on average and then the variance
describes how stable the prediction rule
is so how much can the answer or the
prediction change if I change the input
little bit okay and so you'd like to
have zero for both of these but that's
usually not possible and so if you have
too much variance then their predictions
you make or the decision rule can vary
wildly based on changes in the input so
you have a possibility of overfitting
whereas if you use a model that's too
simple you'll probably have something
with very low variance but extremely
high bias so if if the particular model
you produce like a simple linear model
or a decision stump doesn't actually
describe the phenomenon that you're
trying to model then that's a that's the
source of bias but generally we are we
are okay with a little bit of bias if we
can if we get a good a good reduction in
variance okay so this is kind of a
general phenomenon having that doesn't
doesn't apply only to decision trees but
this is a way to view the the ensemble
the ensemble increasi Jers so the random
forest can be can be viewed as a way of
reducing variance so if you train
individual trees which are extremely
deep they go down until you can't even
split the data anymore the individuals
will have extremely low bias but very
high variance and if you average them
hopefully you keep the bias low and
reduce the variance so you kind of get
the best of both worlds
whereas boosting is generally understand
stumps I didn't make up a term by the
way I think it's lares though the
individuals you you produce are
extremely high bias because it's very
unlikely the thing you're trying to
model is can be described by a single
feature and a threshold on it but also
very low variance so you can change the
input and you're gonna get the same
decision rule if you've just picked a
single feature and threshold and then
the iterations of boosting where you
change the weights and training decision
trees can be viewed as reducing the bias
and then you may have some concerns that
if you do this too many times you will
introduce variance and therefore
overfitting but one thing we'll will see
later is that deep trees may be okay to
use in the boosting framework and in any
case there may be a type of convergence
for the for the boosting procedure
okay so now I'll move to some more
specific statistical arguments for for
the for the random forests or for the
for the for analyzing trees in general
and this some of this is drawn from a
paper by leo breiman so again we we give
ourselves this context of a two class
problem on a d-dimensional euclidean
space and we use decision trees which
have a certain number T of terminal
nodes and each node is a one variable
split okay and then one thing Brian
approves in this paper is that the class
of the class of trees is complete in the
sense that you can basically approximate
any function as long as the number of
nodes is larger than the dimension of
the input space okay and the the main
idea of this proof so it only it only
takes a page I think is to construct an
indicator function for a d-dimensional
rectangle which is to say a function
which is one exactly on that rectangle
and zero everywhere else so it seems you
have this you can produce you can
approximate any function at least with
respect to the l2 norm and so in
particular if you can approximate
anything you can find some linear
combination of decision trees that
converges to any minimizer of the
expected loss function which is the the
thing that's driving the the training
procedure ok and so when people talk
about neural nets they often talk about
these so called a universal
approximation theorems and whenever you
introduce a new one you generally prove
some approximation theorem so this is
the analog of that for decision trees or
for ensembles of decision trees hey you
can you can approximate any function
with this class provided you're allowed
linear combinations okay so that tells
you that there is a way to combine
decision trees that minimizes the the
loss function but it doesn't tell you
how to find one so like we need some
some algorithms and so now I'll sort of
combine arguments that Brian gave with
some slightly more specific and maybe
cleaner arguments
from a paper that that tries to
interpret statistically the adaptive
boosting procedure so the the general
idea is that you want to produce a
function which is say very large on
class one and very large negative on
class -1 so you want to separate the two
classes with this sum function capital F
that's defined on your input space which
is a d-dimensional euclidean space so
there are many ways to formulate this as
an optimization problem one way is to
say that you'd like to minimize the
expected exponential loss which is the
exponential of minus y times capital F
over all of the training set where I'm
thinking of an individual example as a d
dimensional vector X and a plus or minus
1 label y okay and this kind of fits
with the description above because the
the contribution to that expectation for
class 1 is the exponential of minus F so
if I want that to be small I want F to
be really freaking huge
and if Y is minus 1 the contribution is
the exponential of F so I want I want
capital F to be a very large negative
thing so that so that I don't get a
large contribution to the loss ok so
that's that's one way to formulate it
and then you can try to think of this
producing a solution to this or an
approximate solution by an iterative
procedure so assume you have some way of
initializing this you have some capital
F we like to find a good update we want
to add something to our to our and to
our candidate solution F and make it a
little bit better ok since we don't know
how to optimize anything but we know how
to handle polynomials the approach is to
use the Taylor expansion of the of the
expected exponential loss which was on
the previous slide and use that to find
the optimal update little F and it turns
out that that can be described in a
fairly simple way in terms of the labels
of the of the of the points in the in
the data set weighted by the exponential
of minus y times the current capital F
so that kind of works for any value C
and then once you know the this
works for NEC you can find the
coefficient C that works best for it and
that turns out to be to echo the the
coefficient that you saw on the first
slide the first slide first slide that
explained the adaptive boosting
procedure okay so from for a theory for
sort of abstract theoretical reasons we
know that we can find a good a good
linear combination of decision trees in
terms of minimizing the expected loss
but that's a gigantic space the space of
all functions on a d-dimensional
euclidean space is too large to just
throw some algorithm at and so instead
we say well let's find a way to start
and find a way to produce incremental
updates which which make our solution
better and that turns out to be a
statistical characterization of what the
the boosting procedure does which was
not available at the time the the
boosting procedure was first introduced
okay any any questions on this so I'm
about to move to the kind of game theory
approach but any any questions so far
I'm not sure if there's any intuition
it's it's more of a computation it just
comes from from calculus so I think in a
lot of places
I mean it's related to the exponential
in the X and the same sorts of arguments
can work for different choices of loss
function it just happens that when you
use the exponential loss you get this
particular collection of formulas but
the particular formulas are maybe not as
important as the as the general approach
of defining some some loss function and
then optimizing it by this by this
incremental iterative procedure yeah
so the oh maybe I should repeat the
question is about the convergence rate
so so this particular argument just uses
the Taylor expansion of
up to a degree two and then it turns out
that the degree 2 term doesn't really
matter so it becomes a much simpler
problem yeah so we can't do anything
except polynomials so we just pretend
that the higher degree terms don't
matter I think the I mean you can bound
the just by by general calculus you can
bound the size of the error and then in
a particular case that may or may not be
acceptable okay
so let's have a slightly different view
of this boosting boosting procedure so
this view comes from game theory a paper
called prediction games or predictions
games that looks like a typo so first we
define a couple of quantities so if we
have a bunch of weights and a bunch of
classifiers again possibly resulting
from a boosting procedure then we can
find the margin at some input as the the
weighted basically the the weighted
correctness minus the weighted error
okay so the the capital I is just an
indicator so for every for every example
where the classifier is is correct I
give myself positive that weight and for
every example where it's what wrong I
subtract I subtract that weight okay so
that defines the margin at some input
and then and then you can produce the
weighted error of the classifier as a
whole okay so now you can think of you
can think of this set up from the
standpoint of two adversaries playing
against each other so here's a here's a
game does anybody want to play so we we
fix a set of available classifiers okay
gM so these could be anything they could
be decision trees and that's what will
apply to but the framework framework is
somewhat more general so the game goes
as follows player 1 chooses a training
sample like Row 3 a particular
transaction on a credit card and player
2 chooses a bunch of weights for the
classifiers and then player 1 wins the
weighted error
associated with that waiting and that
training example it sounds like so much
fun so in this situation you can you can
see you can construct a so-called payoff
matrix I don't know if you can see that
or not it's kind of a crappy matrix
anyway but basically the columns
correspond to classifiers and the rows
correspond to training examples and it's
just telling you what happens what
happens in that example so in other
words does the classifier get it get it
right or wrong so the first entry is 1
if the classifier gets it correct and -
and the second entry is minus 1
otherwise otherwise the other way around
ok and then in this situation there's
the so-called mixed strategy equilibrium
by general results in game theory and
what this means is that player 1 well
you can't just announce the sample
you're gonna pick because someone can
beat you very easily but you can
announce the probability measure on the
training samples and player 2 can
announce the sort of probability measure
which we're thinking of as a weighting
on the columns and neither player will
have an incentive to change their
strategy and furthermore you can
describe the value of the game or the
expected value of the game the expected
gain for player 1 or loss for player 2
and it's exactly this minimum maximum or
maximum minimum margin okay so this
gives you another another way of
thinking about the classification
problem in general and how to make a
weighted collection of classifiers which
individually may not be so good and now
you think ok I understand what the
boosting procedure is doing it's trying
to it's trying to play this game it's
trying to increase this margin so why
don't we just do that directly like why
do we mess around with all this with all
this calculus why don't we just try to
calculus as described earlier why don't
we just maximize the value of this game
let's just do that
well Brian did that so you think you
know what the algorithm is doing you
just try to do it directly and of course
the result does have better margins
because that's the thing you're
optimizing but it's generalization error
at least in the in the examples that
that he considered were
worse than the boosting procedure so
it's a kind of fascinating conundrum
okay you can say that yes yes so it
could just yeah so it could be that or
it could just be that it has more bias
actually yeah there's the yeah there's
both the the error on the on the test
set and how much that differs from the
error on the training set and I don't
remember exactly how that decomposes in
this example okay no more games okay so
now we move to some ideas from dynamical
systems and so the the the general idea
of this paper and and this view of the
boosting algorithm is that we will show
that certain certain functions of the
weights converge as we continue to boost
okay as long as long as the the number
of boosting iterations is very large
compared to the size of the input set
okay and if the weights converge then
any interesting quantity you would want
to know about the classifier will also
converge for example its generalization
error and so the idea is to view it as a
dynamical system and then hope that some
theoretical conditions can be it can be
shown to hold at least in some examples
and then apply some theorems
guaranteeing convergence okay so so what
we'll do is fix a training set of some
size still Capital n and also a
hypothesis class so a hypothesis is
something like it could be described in
terms of inequalities on the coordinates
it's just another way of formulating the
same same idea and so once you have a
collection of hypotheses this determines
for you some available mistake
dichotomies which is to say just label
for each training example was this
hypothesis
correct or incorrect on that exemple
okay so a parameter space for how to be
disappointed in the classifier okay and
there's also a state space which is the
collection of weights you can put on the
training examples this is an N
dimensional simplex okay and then we
assume specified for example by the
boosting procedure or something else a
learning function which says given a
labeled training set and a bunch and a
bunch of weights choose for me a new
hypothesis and then of course once we
have that hypothesis we can see where is
it wrong okay and there's a little bit
of geometry so you can think of the the
procedure of hypothesis selection as
partitioning the this simplex in two
different regions so for some available
for some mistake dichotomy you can ask
what are the weights for which this this
dichotomy is best and this will chop up
your simplex into some pieces and I
probably people to explain exactly how
this thing how this is used but the the
basic idea is that every time you update
the weights you can view this as
applying some function from the simplex
to itself so you select the best you
have a bunch of weights you select the
BET the best hypothesis you see where
you see where it's errors are and then
you use that to do a reading so that
whole procedure can be described as a
function from the simplex to itself and
then if you're I'm not an expert in
dynamical systems but when you have a
when when you're in this situation
that's it's common to define the so
called attracting set which is the set
of points that can be written so again
so we we take the open subset of the
simplex which can be written as a as the
result of applying an arbitrary number
of iterations of this procedure to a
point in the interior so called
attracting set so where would the stuff
go if you kept inside the simplex where
would everything where would everything
be attracted to if you kept applying
this waiting this this adaboost rule
over and over again and then some
general theorems imply that certain
functions sort
functions in this case of the weights
will converge in particular the the
decision boundary and the generalization
error will converge as the number of
boosting iterations increases okay so in
the interest of time maybe I won't
I won't mention the details but it's
kind of a nice idea to see what are the
theoretical conditions that would imply
the convergence of the boosting
algorithm and then how do you actually
check those in some particular example
it's not that that's not so clear okay
but one thing that emerges from this is
that if you believe that the boosting
procedure converges then you can kind of
say that the random forest and boosting
procedures are the same in the sense
that they are both drawing trees from
some distribution and then predicting
when to thing predicting based on in
what terminal node or in what terminal
nodes an example belongs to okay so in
in the random forest and then maybe also
the boosting procedure if you believe
the convergence result the probability
that two examples land in the same node
can be expressed as a sum over the sum
over the terminal regions and then a
bunch of draws from the distribution
from which the trees are drawn from
which the trees are created and if we
and if we have this view then it appears
that the all these tree methods can be
views viewed as kernel methods so if we
denote this probability by by capital K
then the decision rule can be described
in terms of the result of you know
fixing the first coordinate at X and
then you can try to study the shape of
this kernel as you vary the the way you
construct the trees so in one version so
in one version you might say I will
choose a completely random feature and a
completely random value threshold for
that feature and in that case the kernel
will not have any preferred directions
so that the the probability or the
proximity to some to some little X in
terms of this from the viewpoint of this
random forest will basically be a
function of the
distance to that point so it won't care
exactly where you are it'll just want to
know how close you are the further away
you are the less likely we are to land
up in the same note as that little X as
you get closer you're more likely to
land in the same terminal node as that X
but there doesn't care about the
direction it only cares about the
distance and in this situation their
kernel is symmetric and the individual
classifiers that you produce will be
highly uncorrelated with each other but
not so strong and if instead you try to
do something slightly more intelligent
in each node something more deliberate
the kernel will become more skewed and
that's because the the terminal regions
are trying to be more pure to be to look
like mostly class 1 and very little of
class -1 or the other way around and in
this case the individuals that belong to
the ensemble are better classifiers but
they are also more correlated with each
other ok and now some pictures so here's
after all this theory it's a it's a
we're trying to distinguish the inside
is for inside of a circle from the
outside of a circle like what is going
on but anyway this is the this is the
example that is hopefully rich enough to
show some of these ideas so yeah so
we're trying to distinguish the inside
from the outside of a circle but using
cuts which are parallel to the axes so
it's not so clear you can do this so in
one approach we'll use a on the it'll be
the left hand side will do the we'll use
a random forest where we choose a
feature at random by the way there are
two features and then we'll pick the
best split for that feature the one that
best separates the classes and then we
have an even random or forest to be seen
on the right where we choose a random
feature again there are two and then a
random value for that feature okay and
then we we use this as a as an input to
the general random forest machinery or
the general random tree machinery and
then and then I'll throw away some of
the easy examples just to to bring it to
focus the interesting stuff so on the on
the left hand side you can you can
hopefully see that the decision boundary
is increasing or changing very rapidly
in a neighborhood of
of the circle so it's very tight around
the around the actual decision boundary
and that's because we are being a little
a little bit more deliberate about how
we make our individual decisions so
we're choosing a feature at random but
we're choosing the best threshold and so
the kernel is kind of skewed or it takes
into account the structure of the
decision boundary whereas on the right
hand side where we pick a feature and a
threshold at random the kernel looks a
lot more like blobs which are symmetric
which are rotationally invariant at
least about each point and if you think
about making a decision rule out of
those it's going to be harder to cut
it's going to be harder to have a sharp
cut around this decision boundary so
you'll still be able to distinguish the
two classes but the way the the decision
function changes will be more gradual in
a neighborhood of the decision boundary
okay and then you can also examine where
they disagree above a threshold and so
the the last thing I want to I want to
mention is this conundrum which is that
these procedures tend to perfectly fit
the training data and yet have a small
generalization error and so maybe I'll
just immediately go to some pictures of
boosting okay so it's the same same type
of example and now we again just to have
a decision stump
okay so we're trying to distinguish the
inside from the outside of a circle with
one with one cut which is which is
parallel to the axes so not much you can
do somehow you break the symmetry and
choose one okay now you increase the
weights on the examples where you got it
wrong so where's the next one gonna be
on the other side great doing better so
on the on the left side you have the
decision the probability and on the
right side you have it cut at some
threshold I think I mean the class is
equally weighted so it's probably cut at
point five now let's keep going I want
to I want to keep boosting okay you do a
couple more you cut off the top and the
bottom so now you're you're trying to
approximate a circle with a square are
you done no so you keep going to ten
you start to slice off a little bit more
and then at 100 it kind of looks like a
circle so you somehow we've come up with
a weighted weighted linear combination
of cuts which are parallel to the axes
which basically look like basically
looks like a circle okay and then the
very last topic which I have one minute
is a study of how the boosting procedure
behaves in some example as you increase
the depth of the base learner so in the
iterations I've I've shown in this
example where we're trying to
distinguish the inside from the outside
of a circle I use the decision stump so
just one one feature one threshold now
let's let's study how in a different
example how the behavior varies as a
function of the depth okay so I draw I
draw my inputs from a twenty dimensional
square and then I have a certain
probability of being class one which is
some formula based on the which
basically depends on the first five
coordinates otherwise I'm class minus
one okay and then so I don't visible so
the the cyan color is is step one that
the legend is telling you the depth the
vertical axis is the error so lower is
better and the horizontal axis is the
number of boosting iterations so if you
just focus on the cyan that's telling
you how this behaves for depth one base
learner and so initially it's better and
then if you look at the dark blue that's
step three
it starts out worse and then it gets
better the green is step five and the
red is depth ten and so initially the
using the decision stumps or shorter
trees in general has a better
performance but as the number of
iterations increases the performance
actually gets better for the deeper
treat the boosting ensembles created
with deeper decision trees as a as a
base learner okay
that's that's right so they so we could
keep going I believe that they will all
become basically horizontal lines it
would be great if they would all get
better as the number of iterations
increases but that's not true so yes
yeah and I did this once on a single
data set you're supposed to you're
supposed to do this lots of times and
produce confidence errors and the
confidence intervals and such yes so my
understanding is so the question is how
this compares to actually booths so so
my understanding is that so I'm not
familiar with all the details of extra
boost but it's essentially a form of
adaptive boosting with a lot of nice
heuristics built in for to make the
tuning easier I'm I'm not sure what what
algorithmic novelties there are but it
very much fits into this fits into this
framework
yeah
so that's it I'm happy to stick around
for questions here or or elsewhere
[Applause]